the tributes are starting to fade now
but the memory of what happened here is
still
vivid a security camera recorded
an attacker charging at an elderly man
and barging him to the ground
visha ratana pakti an 84 year old
grandfather
died two days later one victim in a
surge of violence
against america's asian community
in their grief his family want to share
the story
every time i see the picture when he
chop
pushed out on the ground and it's
terrible
for me and really that
made me stand up and raise awareness for
the asian community
to stand up and don't be silent anymore
little comments that people make to
themselves when they're at the bar you
know just all these little things they
they add
up and somehow people feel like it's
okay for them to tee off on asians
[Music]
a man's been charged with killing mr
ratana pakhti
his death had already shown a light on
this issue even before the murder of
eight people
six of them women of asian descent in
atlanta
and all of those we spoke to pointed to
this
science medicine will eradicate the
china virus once and for all donald
trump's blaming of china for the
coronavirus
is contributing to the climate of hate
in san francisco's chinatown there are
volunteer patrols to reassure the
community
but they say trump bears responsibility
when you're a world leader what you say
really matters
it's not just chinese people getting
attacked
it's filipinos it's cambodians
everybody's getting attacked and it's
just not right
typically asians they don't come out
they don't speak out but
more and more people are saying we're
not going to be silent anymore
and i'm so glad that we woke up a
sleeping giant
but some like danny yu-chang attacked
during his lunch break
are now moving out i've been living here
for the past 21 years
and this is the first time that these
things happen to me well the asian
people are afraid to go out
in fact a lot of people are
moving out of california and moving to
some other parts of america
and and it's so sad uh this is not the
old san francisco anymore
america was already facing a reckoning
on race hate of course but
anti-asian hate was rarely discussed
what the community says
will take more than slogans to bring to
an end greg milam sky news
san francisco